uh particularly with this new comedy
special we should tell everybody
so it's called legalize everything and
the [ __ ] eric andre is out of his
goddamn mind it's insane
and it's [ __ ] it's fantastic and
hilarious um
but largely your your new netflix
special
is about your drug experiences i mean
you're just
just coming in hot tired you're like
running through
with the cocaine you know the helmet the
with the cocaine straws and
yeah i got starting to hotmail with the
ref or something yeah
yeah yeah i i love the joke about uh i
got my [ __ ] crystal meth card
my medicinal crystal bath card [ __ ]
genius
and you're talking about all the the
acids your favorite drug and
you know i'm getting stoned with my mom
and at a certain point i gotta wonder
a how much of that is true like you know
this enthusiasm for drugs
and uh and b do you ever get concerned
that being so
pro-drug and pro-taking drugs
uh if that's gonna have any kind of uh
like you know a detrimental effect you
know
i think there's a difference between
drug use and drug abuse
and i think that if you take crystal
meth medicinally
yes exactly it made me think about
cleaning from the doctors i want to get
a service rattlesnake
[Laughter]
yeah um no i i think well i 100 smoked
pot with my mom
um that's a true story it used to be my
favorite joke but i actually think
honestly
coffee is my favorite drug yeah i
pounded every show man i
drank that drink i don't know this is a
[ __ ] i drink it every day
it's always good to me i don't crash
i it just makes me happy it makes me
creative
coffee out of all the drugs i've done is
by far the best one it's like just
the most consistent never lets you down
coffee is the number one
imported exported drug in the world do
you have a cutoff point
like is there a time of day that you
won't drink coffee after i
i only do a cup or two in the morning
because um
if i do it after lunch or if i do a lot
of espresso
i can't sleep i have too much on my mind
i'm too anxious what time do you solve
crystal meth
the method is around like four or
fourteen is it true that uh
is it true that you bought an eight ball
of cocaine in new orleans one time
i think i changed that town to town that
that eight ball story where i go
i ripped it and i was like i think i
just knew the drywall is actually from
when i
bought it off the streets in costa rica
in this like touristy beach town
from a shade ball dude and i was with my
ding dong friends
and they were like let's let's buy coke
off a shady
shady magoo and i was like yeah of
course that's a great idea
and i [ __ ] ripped the line and i was
like
that was 90 drywall 10 baby laxative
tile at all yeah i would expect that you
would get good cocaine in costa rica
see like for example the best coke i
ever had was in in brazil
brazil okay that was that was real i
heard the really really good coke
is like blue or it's like a different
different color
it's like off-white off-white like a
little yellow
and yeah i never saw that in my uh
you know cocaine cowboys documentary you
ever did coke in south america
dude like mike's this is gonna people
will call me a bad person for sharing
this but
anybody who's going to mexico as a
tourist
just a little piece of information for
you every single
[ __ ] taxi driver in uh and say cancun
or acapulco
just say hey man i want cocaine they'll
either have it under their seat in the
taxi cab
or they'll go to the taxicab stand and
just get it from the
the guy right there but you every single
maybe in all of mexico but definitely
cancun
every single taxi driver is also a
cocaine dealer
in mexico and for that matter the
cocaine is like really pretty [ __ ]
good
man it's like powerful cocaine coming
from these taxi
guys the prices are all over the place
but then
like watch out when you're in the
bathroom because the bathroom attendant
guy
if he hears you snorting in the bathroom
these little [ __ ] [ __ ] will
like climb over or under [ __ ] they'll
grab you and then you got to bribe them
to get out of it
that sucks yeah that happened
i think we might have even been in costa
rica we had that same thing happen to us
but by what do i want did they come over
or wrong
i can't remember how old were you when
you first got
high steve were you doing drugs since
you were like 12 um
no first time smoking pot 16.
what about your first time drunk first
time drunk uh
i mean i've been like on my own
initiative i was 12.
what about you eric first time doing
acid
i asked not till i was like 21 but uh
drunk we would we would we would
get not 40 ounces because they were only
they were illegal in in florida we would
get quarts of old english for saint eyed
special brew
we would listen i had a mix tape with
all these different easy e songs on it
and we were listening to easy e on our
walkman or
cd disc man and skateboard poorly and
drink
quarts of old english until we threw up
that was like in like
in like plantation in fort lauderdale
and hollywood
and like i had like my alien workshop
skateboard i couldn't even ollie and i
would just like
drink and listen to easy dozen to like
[ __ ] puke
like rainbow-colored saint-eyed special
bro drink like mad dog 2020
wine coolers so gross
thank you so much for watching this clip
and guess what
i have the number 30 ranked hot sauce on
all of amazon it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
order yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude